an increasing number of people they are
turning to social media to pick their
next vacation spot especially the
Millennials a recent study found 60% of
millennial travelers are on Instagram
that's a three hundred and seventy five
percent increase from 2013 other
research shows more than 40 percent of
people under the age of thirty three
prioritize or Instagram ability of a
location to help them decide where to
vacation next Mark Elwood is
contributing editor of Conde Nast
Traveler and joins us to discuss so
we're looking at the pictures and we're
looking at other people's pictures to
decide where we're going yeah we're not
going we're not picking a vacation
destination and taking a picture once we
get there we're thinking can I get a
great picture if I can't I'm not gonna
go so it's it's changed how we even take
pictures these days you think I think
it's we used to take pictures to look
happy now we take them to look kind of
hot and sexy a lot of the instagrams
you've got to look a little sexier in
the past you just grinned this explains
why my Instagram is so barren New
Zealand
and what's Iceland are to popular
destination I think what you you can see
the impact of Instagram on tourism there
because New Zealand is one of the
hottest destinations in the world
partly because its scenery is so
Instagram about it looks like the moon
yeah New Zealand has an area that
focused on Instagram in its tourism
marketing numbers went up 14% but I
think the most interesting part is a
place in Norway where there's a rock
that you can sit on and look very sort
of contemplative 2009 that area got 500
visitors 2014 it got 40,000 and it's
funny because I will admit we've booked
travel based on where I've seen my
friends go that just looks so amazing
yes but it's you say that hotels are now
changing their a business model and
trying to become in-store friendly -
tell us about think about that when you
walk into a hotel lobby take a moment
and look around and think what about the
design here is intended to be
photographed they're not white anymore
they're bright colors there's a hotel in
Sydney called the 1888 that has a selfie
area with a little gold frame and you
can go in and take a picture think
there's the lobby of the hotel Indigo in
downtown LA has a giant chandelier
that's supposed to be Instagram
just stop and think and you can totally
see the hotels want you to take pictures
you said that 70% of Instagram is travel
70% 70% is travel related I don't
believe I think I think that shows you
how impactful Instagram has been on
travel how native it is think about that
40 percent of Millennials who won't go
somewhere unless they can Instagram it
that's that baking Instagram into travel
remember I think people thought that
travel agents or travel specialists as
we call them now we're sort of like
phone booths and record stores they were
kind of old school right gone gone gone
no no they're largely on Instagram now
they're using Instagram to book you're
using it as a business model there's a
great Instagram are called Jessica on a
bongo she focuses on Africa she has
really far-flung destinations but she's
also a travel specialist how do people
find her Instagram and people are
looking cute in their pictures I thought
vacation pictures were boring with
people getting dolled up in their poet
they're packing biggest suitcases I
think that what luggage allowance needs
to go up so you got more outfit okay
thank you Mark Elwood always good to
have you here